this year's nominees for makeup run the
gamut from transforming a woman so she
could live like a man in 19th century
Ireland to the fantasy world of wizards
to replicating one of the most iconic
leaders of the 20th century here are the
nominees for achievement and makeup
Albert Nobbs
Marcia carnival Lynn Johnston and Mackay
Uwe Boll Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows part-2 Nick Dudman Amanda night
and Lisa Tomlin the Iron Lady mark Kooy
air and Jay Roy Helen well you take a
chance
hello take a chance the Iron Lady mark
mark cool ear says his biggest challenge
was finding the right
between adding stuff to create Margaret
Thatcher without losing meryl streep
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for mark Kooy and jail or
Helen
Thank You Academy and thank you to my
colleague on the Iron Lady mark Coulier
without whose brilliant prosthetics I
wouldn't be standing here this evening
thanks Mero
for keeping me employed for the last 37
years your brilliance makes my work look
good no matter what I'm a child of the
Saturday and Sunday double-double
features so getting to work in the
movies is a dream come true thank you
just like to say what an amazing
experience
thanks to Meryl you were incredible and
just a quick thank you to Barry Gower
and Stephen Murphy
and my kids Isabelle Ethan my wife
Amanda and my dad thank you
you